eHarmony is an
online dating site
focused on long
term relationships.
It takes a scientific
approach to love and marriage.
About nearly 4% of
US marriages in 2012
are a result of eHarmony.
The company has
generated over $1 billion
in cumulative revenue from
2000, the year it was founded.
The overall approach
first predicts
if users will be compatible
using 29 different dimensions
of personality and
using linear regression.
Then using optimization,
eHarmony finds
matches for everyone.
eHarmony has members in
more than 150 countries.
Since launching in 2000, it has
more than 33 million members,
and it now operates eHarmony
Labs, a relationship research
facility.
eHarmony collects data
through 436 questions.
Almost 15,000 people take
the questionnaire each day.
What is the edge of eHarmony?
It relies much more on data
than other dating sites.
It suggests a limited number
of high quality matches.
Users don't have to search
and dig through profiles.
eHarmony has successfully
leveraged the power
of analytics to create a
successful and thriving
business.
It represents 14% of the
US online dating market.